let's talk about ancient verse modern
Olympics how did the ancient games
created by the Greeks in 776 BC compared
to the modern Olympics specifically
Sochi ancient Olympics featured track
and field events like javelin discus and
the Pankratz on a brutal hybrid form of
wrestling boxing where everything was
legal
except biting and eye gouging the modern
Olympics has curling and 400 other
awesome events like ski jumping a plane
skiing but nothing quite as intense as
the modern Olympic Games have been
hosted by 40 different cities over 204
nations have participated the ancient
Olympics were held every year at Olympia
Greece and only Greek men could compete
in modern times false starts illegal
equipment and steroids get punished by
disqualifications or bans 63 athletes
have even been stripped of their medals
if you made a false start in the ancient
Olympics they beat the crap out of
ancient Greek historian Herodotus called
it a sound thrashing modern Olympic
uniforms are the pinnacle of performance
speedos spent millions of dollars on new
swimsuit just to shave off milliseconds
whereas ancient Olympians were stark
naked the sweat on their glorious bodies
glistening in the Sun and no amount of
fancy spandex can ever top that the
ancient
wins the gold your move Sochi
[Music]